PRESSURE MEXICO TO STOP THEM
FIRST OTHERWISE THERE WILL BE
PROCESS LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
CLAIMING ASYLUM.
BRET?
>> Bret: WILLIAM, THANK YOU.
LET'S GET'S OFFICIAL RESPONSE
FROM THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT TO
THE NEWS OF THIS CARAVAN AND THE
CRITICISM FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS AND HIS ADMINISTRATION.
HIERONYMUS GUTIERREZ, THE
MEXICAN AMBASSADOR TO THE
U.S.
THANK YOU FOR COMING HERE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Bret: YOUR THOUGHTS ON
TODAY, WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
TWEETED, WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
I THINK?
>> THANK YOU, FIRST, FOR THE
CHANCE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THIS EVENING.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT, IT HAS
RAISED THE TENSION HERE.
TWO QUICK THINGS.
THE FIRST WITNESS, MEXICO'S
MIGRATION POLICY IS TO SEEK THAT
ANY MIGRATION IS LEGAL, SAFE,
ORDERLY, AND RESPECTFUL OF BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND THAT'S THE WAY WE ACT UPON
IT, IMMIGRATION.
WE CERTAINLY DO NOT ADVOCATE FOR
REGULAR IMMIGRATION FROM OUR
NATIONALS OF OR ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
THE SECOND THING IS THAT IN FACT
OUR AUTHORITIES, U.S. AND MY
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOOD
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOOO
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOON
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOOT
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOOE
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOOM
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOOT
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOOE
MEXICO COOPERATION, IS VERY GOO.
LAST YEAR, WE CONVENED A JOINT
SUMMIT IN MIAMI PRECISELY TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER, TO
FOSTER DEVELOPMENT, AND CENTRAL
AMERICAN COUNTRIES.
IN ORDER REALLY TO ADDRESS THE
ROOT PROCESS OF IMMIGRATION.
AND ALSO TO DO A BETTER JOB
MANAGING IMMIGRATION IN A WAY
THAT IS LEGAL, SAFE, AND
ORDERLY.
>> Bret: SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
CARAVAN, UNDERSTANDING THAT IT
DOES HAPPEN ANNUALLY, AND THAT
IT'S USED BY SOME GROUPS AS A
FUND-RAISING ACTIVITY REALLY.
ARE YOU GOING TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THIS YEAR?
>> WE ARE DOING, FIRST OF ALL,
NUMBER ONE, THE FIRST THING,
THIS IS NOT NEW.
IT IS LARGELY INTENDED TO CALL
ATTENTION ON THE RIGHTS OF
MIGRANTS IN MEXICO.
NUMBER TWO IS OUR MIGRATION
AUTHORITIES ARE LOOKING AT AS
APPROPRIATE EITHER TO REPATRIATE
THESE PEOPLE OR TO OFFER
HUMANITARIAN RELIEF TO THEM AND
MEXICO.
BY THE WAY, WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH THE U.S. EMBASSY
SINCE MARCH 25TH.
THAT IS WHY I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY THESE ISSUES THIS
EVENING.
>> Bret: MR. AMBASSADOR, YOUR
COUNTRY HAS PRETTY STRICT
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
YOU, AS WILLIAM MENTIONED,
DEPORT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
HONDURANS AND SALVADORANS AND
GUATEMALANS EVERY YEAR.
>> WE DO.
IT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
ALL NATIONS, THE CENTRAL
AMERICANS COME OUR SELF, AND THE
U.S., TO ASSURE THAT PEOPLE
DON'T MIGRATE IRREGULARLY.
IT'S ACTUALLY VERY DANGEROUS.
AND THAT IS WHY FOR EXAMPLE IN
2016, MEXICO REPATRIATED,
RESPECTING THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE,
REPATRIATED AROUND 153,000
CENTRAL AMERICANS.
>> Bret: >> Bret: THAT'S
>> Bret: >> Bret: THAT'SA
>> Bret: >> Bret: THAT'SL
>> Bret: >> Bret: THAT'ST
>> Bret: >> Bret: THAT'SO
>> Bret: >> Bret: THAT'S
>> Bret: >> Bret: THAT'ST
OF PEOPLE.
>> IN 2017, THAT NUMBER WAS
AROUND A HUNDRED THOUSAND.
THE FIGURES FOR THIS YEAR IS
AROUND 40,000.
SO WE DO WORK TO ASSURE THAT
MIGRATION IS LEGAL, SAFE, AND
ORDERLY.
>> Bret: IN THAT SENSE, YOU
UNDERSTAND WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP